bonjour à tous ces clichés en haute
clichés l'émission qui discutent des
clichés qui servent à combattre les
clichés en paléontologie
aujourd'hui on vous parle des dinosaures
et notamment lequel était le plus féroce
suspense mises en situation et bah moi
je dis que c'est le tyrannosaure le plus
féroce d'abord mais pas du tout le plus
féroce d'abord si le spinosaures ou
alors tient le gie guaino deux heures
c'est le plus féroce parce qu'il est
plus gros il a pris 2 alors la notion de
férocité chez des espèces éteintes et
notamment chez les dinosaures est ce que
c'est pertinent est ce que ça ne l'est
pas on va faire un autre groupe
aujourd'hui entre la férocité et le mot
redoutable parce que je pense que les
deux ont été bien user et abuser
au fil des années alors déjà dans notre
mise en situation
la notion de férocité et complètement
interchangeables avec la notion de
taille plus on est gros et plus on est
féroce alors est ce que c'est vrai ça
déjà nous si on compare avec l'actuel ça
marche pas du tout parce que par exemple
au niveau des carnivores on a des
espèces qui sont très grandes comme les
lions qui sont pas vraiment si féroce
que ça ton plus peureuse d'ailleurs
qu'autre chose rappelant des espèces qui
sont beaucoup plus petites comme l'eau
solo qui carnivores sud-américains qui
lui par contre extrêmement féroce et qui
attaquent à peu près tout ce qui passe
et donc tout ça pour dire que la taille
clairement n'a aucune incidence sur la
ce qu'on appelle l'affairé aussi
exactement et puis en plus si on y
rajoute la notion de redoutables on peut
être féroce et pas forcément redoutable
des six nations qui sont différentes
techniquement le petit roquet de votre
voisine l'espèce de tout petit truc va
peut-être être très féroce il va vouloir
vous sauter à la gorge alors que au
mollet au mollet sont tous ces trucs là
bon bref c'est tout petit et c'est pas
forcément redoutable mais par contre ça
peut être même parler des fourmis dans
ce cas est de 2 dans notre mise en
situation la férocité était complètement
misant synonymie avec le fait d'être
carnivores mais est-ce que ça c'est vrai
aussi est-ce qu'on est forcément plus
féroce et redoutable quand on est
carnivore
non pas forcément parce que clairement
les hippopotames c d abord je pas bien
du tout et par contre on va éviter de se
tenir près d'un dépôt parce que c'est un
peu dangereux assez redoutable déjà de
manière générale à un herbivore ses
redoutables ne serait-ce que ce soit par
la masse donc lamaserie nombre c'est à
dire si vous avez beaucoup d'herbivores
qui vous foncent dessus
clairement ces redoutables oui ou alors
année défaut ou alors à l'aller face est
énorme tout seul et c'est très
redoutable si ça veut l'être
voilà donc maintenant vous combinez les
deux à troupeau d'un bateau russe je
pense que c'est beaucoup plus redoutable
que n'importe quel dinosaures carnivores
des films même sans vouloir être féroce
d'ailleurs parce que tout simplement ils
ont aucune idée de ce qui se passe en
dessous de janvier il serait question
n'existe même pas voilà donc déjà il ya
ça et en plus un herbivore ça peut
totalement être féroce notamment en
période de reproduction exactement même
si vous avez déjà vu des girafes en
train de se taper dessus avec leur long
cou croyez moi c'est un fou dangereux et
vous voulez mal dans le passage non en
fait il ya plus de morts par girafe tous
les ans que de morts par aliou 130 et
l'asie peau sans compter les hippos il
ya main en plus les icônes ya encore
plus de morts que par girafe et si on se
replonge à l'époque des dinosaures non
aviens évidemment on va se retrouver
avec des dinosaures qui devait être très
farouchement territoriaux notamment les
herbivores
si vous regardez par exemple du côté des
cératopsidés c'est auxerre qui ont de
grandes ornementations sur leurs crânes
des ornementations visuel comme la
collerette mais aussi des ornementations
dangereuses comme les cornes
tout ça ça indique quand même des
animaux qui devait être très
farouchement ce territoriaux notamment
en période de reproduction
et à mon avis même replonger au crétacé
vous auriez beaucoup plus peur des
tricératops que des tyrannosaures parce
qu'il était vachement plus nombreux
aussi qu'ils ont beaucoup plus
redoutable et je pense qu'il pouvait
être tout autant ference donc au final
la notion de férocité et la notion de
dinosaures redoutable elles sont
totalement dépendantes des définitions
qu'on colle dessus que ce soit la taille
que ce soit le nombre de dents donc
c'est vraiment complètement dépendant de
ce qu'on colle dessus et si on a envie
d'utiliser quelque chose peut-être de
plus scientifique une approche un peu
plus calibré à la notion de férocité bas
on pourrait regarder par exemple nombre
de traces de morsures qui existe dans
registre fossile et là on se rendrait
évidemment compte que c'est
tyrannosaurus le plus féroce parce que
le registre fossile des traces de
morsures de tyrannosaure sur des
ossements d'autres dinosaures il est
juste gigantesque que ce soit des adrs
or que ce soit des ses rentes option que
ce soit d'autre tyrannosaure d'ailleurs
quoi qu'il en soit ces notions de
dinosaures redoutable ou de dinosaures
féroce au final elles ont toujours le
même biais c'est à dire qu'elles sont
arbitraires parce que finalement les
mots féroce et redoutable ils ont été
inventés par les êtres humains pour les
êtres humains pour décrire des
comportements animaux moderne et donc à
dinosaures par définition du coup ça ne
peut pas être féroce ce que les humains
là la seule expérience qu'ils ont de ces
dinosaures basso sur des possibles oui
et puis de toute façon fait rosser
redoutable s'est fait rosser rude étape
pour nous c'est à dire que nous vivons
qu'on n'était pas là à l'époque on peut
pas savoir comment ils sont mais aussi
on n'a jamais subit donc est il
pertinent de dire que les dinosaures
étaient redoutables je pense que non
alors non non attention parce que quand
même on a un petit truc aujourd'hui qui
s'appelle les dinosaures aviens et en
les dinosaures aviens tu vas trouver des
trucs qui sont des cases were here les
cases were pour me dire qu'ils sont pas
un redoutable appareil alors bien alors
les oies les niveaux férocité c'est pas
forcément très redoutable les oies mais
par contre niveau faire aussi t elle
s'en sortent pas mal aimé des gens et
des poules aussi bien ça marche après ça
dépend de toi est ce que tu considères
fait c'est vrai c'est vrai donc quel
était le dinosaure le plus redoutable
moi je pars sur le gasoil mais son tir
donc pour conclure
est-ce que les dinosaures peuvent être
féroce et oui oui mais est-ce que le
giganotosaurus était le plus féroce est
non
voilà c'était clichés sur notre cliché
on vous remercie d'avoir suivi cette
vidéo et on vous dis à très bientôt sur
notre chaîne